the last film
i was talking about the elbows being
brought in when you do that the can cut
can swing whatever you'd like to think
of as
and um i'd like to explain a little more
this time about
how i see her senses
thinking on aikido just one segment of
it really
a friend of mine sent me a tai chi video
tight each one
the marshall fighting applications
how how it would be shown slowly and and
how it be done with a partner
applied to the body what i saw was
shia nagi ikiyo senkyo
kokunagi
and then if we look at dietary you'll
see
techniques that we we name them
all as aikido techniques and i've said
before they're not like you know at all
he took them from other places
i'm wondering if he actually
took so many from different arts
nishio sensei he used to love showing
her
everything with the the weapons
the way a sword would cut where it would
go
up turn use the hilt as a lock for
nikkio then we see the chinese doing the
same
so when people say
does aikido work as a martial art and
the answer
definitely to me is yes
whether you that the exponent doing the
art is any good is a different matter
but if you look around at these
different links of the other martial
arts
they were developed by masters as a
fighting art
and immobilizations
to work on opponents
in fighting skills yes they were days
gone by but the body still got arms and
legs
the same attitudes may have changed
i believe we've become more flexible as
humans
to the old films that i watch when i
watch some of the
early days of judo in the black and
white films
i think hell how unflexible they are
and yet they were great masters
are they just stories that we have heard
that are brought forward these great
wonderful masters
but where they stiff old men against
stiff old men
and in those times did it work
like the rifle one bullet at the time
and now you can get a magazine that will
shoot
70 bullets a moment
anyhow when i wrote my
first book some of you may have
my idea was to show the weaknesses
within the
techniques and we call them aikido
techniques
but since he said that takamoosu was
when a technique would just be created
it would be created a
silly word out of the blue
it would just arrive so if
he took martial arts from all different
parts of
china mongolia japan
from the samurais dietary
you know it's endless
the bayonet the neganata
if he took all these various techniques
and molded them as he saw them
and then teaches them but he taught them
with
an attitude of defeating your
enemy with love rather than
wishing to hurt or kill or maim them
so perhaps he had to modify him slightly
but was the biggest modification
how he thought how his compassion
would be applied within the techniques
did he great gain great power from
universal thinking praying to the kami
did he become a very religious man who
could only see the good in everybody
and if something come his way
it's better to avoid it than to have
conflict
one particular technique i would like to
talk about in this sec
segment is ekio shomenuccio
i've met the current doshu when he was i
think
around 37 years of age in america
i wish at the time i'd have asked him
the question but i didn't
i dare if i left the chance to ask again
but if any aikikai senior rank out there
has the answer i would love to hear from
them
what what your opinion is of this
question i'm going to ask
if ocentsie didn't want
conflict of any description
inside they said to use the word please
go past
and this was always to avoid conflict if
someone done a shamrochi
he would step to the side and go dozer
please you would never stand in front of
a person
and say please go pass without moving
would you
this would be arrogant egotistic
oh sorry and
it wouldn't be keeping within those
senses i killed
as i believe it i'm going to show you
some pictures in my in my book to
explain what i mean
in the aikikai they do a completely
different
ikiyo showman ego
it sounds like i'm always saying iwama's
bestie one was best but
i'm just and perhaps i am i'm trying to
make logical sense i've said many times
those senses aikido is simple aikido
simplified and if it has no
conflict then why would we start putting
conflict
in a movement so
on this page you will see us with two
swords
this is the normal standard
and this one i have got an x against
now why would you ever
put your arm in front
of
why would you ever put your arm in front
of a sword
a real live katana
you know it doesn't make sense does it
and think about it logically
if somebody had a real life katana would
you put your arm up against it
so i'm genuinely asking this question
nobody's ever answered it
the answer i got from a third down aikid
guy teacher once
who runs his own dojo he said
i'd just be quicker and when they raise
up
i quickly go in
i said yes if you're quick enough to go
in before the
on the downstroke we do that any while
mike you know
if we're quick enough to blend then we
blend
and we continue it going up up up
and over the head and down into ikea
i sensei in his book budo
he shows his techniques and he said
i initiate i
initiate so he is the one that initiates
the other person puts their hand up to
meet it
not the other way around if the person
is coming
down for you to put your arm up
so please watch some films and you'll
see what i mean
the aikid practitioner meets it
coming down and they cut it down to the
floor and they call it ikkyo
this is to me going against everything
osensee was
telling me anyhow
why would you enter against the live
sword with your arm you wouldn't
so why do it with without a sword a
clash is a clash
if you have a good answer please be kind
enough to
message me reply on the youtube channel
where it says comments
my whole aikido understanding is
non-conflict art
the techniques are powerful we don't
have to be
the chinese were there a long time ago
developing fighting techniques dai to
rue
all the other arts i've talked about
they're fighting aren't so since he
didn't want to fight he wanted to
neutralize
without harm two arms coming together
and the strongest person winning cutting
down
to me isn't no sense couldn't so why is
it being taught
and what is the purpose of it wouldn't
it be better
to raise my hand when i see their arm
coming down
blend but let it pass by me
with the understanding of dozel please
please go past
step out of the way you could do a coat
of ice you could do something
else in these films i often repeat
myself but i'm hoping that i'll repeat
them in different ways
so that you may think and reconsider
them this has troubled me
for many years back now and i still
cannot make some like teachers
believe me and change it because they're
set in their ways
is part of their career click room so
they feel that they
must do it they can't look at it
in the way that i was taught it
initiate and blend or
if they're the stronger and faster
part let it pass by you
and do another technique don't clash
with it
then you'll start to i believe
understand
i sense psychedelic more fuller fully
and we have a we have a then a much
better journey
looking at how we can do everything in
life
without clashing the art of
non-resistance
if we have to use a martial art let's
use one of those techniques that were
developed
by many of those great masters but let's
not start making up techniques
oh since his son created this technique
not no scentsy he's been carried on
and now he's i says his grandson does it
i'm sure his son will do it and soon the
alarm away in years to come will be lost
but i'm asking you to look at it cleanly
study it tell me the reason why if it
fits in with
please go past i'm not here to clash
or to defeat you you won't be able to
when you get older
against a young faster person so why
not change now thank you for your time